in the event of a fire or other
emergency please exit building an oldy
manner the assembly point which is
located in the modern car plasma the
fire exit is represented by green fire
exit sign please do not delay evacuation
by collecting any belongings do not use
the leaves the premises must not be
reentered until the fire brigade have
given the all-clear
please note it is against the law to
smoke on these premises and please note
this meeting to be audio recorded and
I'm very opposed if you turn your mobile
either off or put it on silent thank you
alright apologies for absence I don't
think there already is no non members
attending thank you as our minutes of
the last meeting if you're agreeable we
are you happy for me to sign them as a
true record indeed any declarations of
interest is receiving discretion
regrettably who's probably applying for
mandatory rate the live so moving
trust that so our suspect is probably
mastermind but he's a non-pecuniary
interest that's how you artwork yeah
what do you want having involvement in
siding we get signal
it's it's no but I'll be up there the
song yeah yeah thank you very much
any others if anybody and that's
interest as we go along please get very
and we'll make sure it goes in the
minutes alright so back to item six so
got me screen go
I survived there on no item so item six
is the next one which is the financial
management performance reform which i
think is rather good song would you like
to what you it's it's just got a tour I
think the the detail is best explained
by matter matter matter home I Happy
Passover okay thank you
I'll turn the attention straightway to
page six point two and the table in
paragraph three point two because this
kind of prints the picture of the whole
reform
I'm pleased to say that the ovary
forecasted position for the end of the
year is eight point six seven million
against the latest budget of eight point
nine seven million giving us just under
three hundred thousand pounds sailing
that compared to when we brought in the
q1 report we would project a savior of
ninety one thousand at that stage this
is an additional two hundred thousand
pound the highlights of that that
additional income mainly reflected
saving on salaries and staff costs a q1
we were we were looking at about fifty
thousand pound saving we're now
reporting a saving of a hundred and
eighty eight thousand pound and that
figure since then was actually gone up a
little bit more but as a q-series
198,000 the other main favorable
variance being our element of the
council tax sharing scheme so this is
where additional council tax is
collected within the district the
element that we paid back to to the
other precept as we get sixteen percent
back so part of the the sharing scheme
that we're involved in so that's that's
generating a really good favorable
variance that's good good news story and
I don't plan on going through the tables
in the report I think they kind of just
give you a bit more details as to that
main table in three point two we do
obviously have some freshers though as
well as having some good news stories we
do have some pressures that are
continuing and one of them being our
homelessness posts particularly around
placing people in temporary combination
Bend breakfast on the know
and one of the recommendations of the
report is that we have approval to draw
down sixty-two thousand pound from
general fund reserve this is this is an
estimated net position that we believe
having detailed discussions with the
ways are in the tenders what we believe
we need to get us through to the end of
this financial year in terms of placing
people in bed-and-breakfast
accommodation I don't think there's
anything else I want to say on revenue
Bobby I'm happy to take questions just
to emphasize the capital position again
it's on track as at this report ninety
eight point eight percent delivery so
you know a long time as I say I could
say Kenny and include questions and just
asking on three point one just
dictionary former that's sort of a
statement there so he says the original
net budget was eight point seven one
million yes I think you've got
additional contributions from reserves
which makes it eight point nine seven
but you've saved one hundred and
forty-one from that eight point nine
seven is that right but then there have
been contributions from reserves to
making it up so it's not quite the
figure yeah when we when we put this
report together there's obviously within
within the year there are movements to
and from reserve but we strip those back
out to give it the clear positions and
that's why I asked so from the net
budget set by the council you're looking
at expenditure
which was a 21 we're looking at 8.3
million is a parade yes the reserved
movements a quite well yes but so it's
actually not quite where it was said if
you see what I mean yeah so yeah I do
see what you mean yeah the original
budget was eight point seven one million
which was what was agreed Leila's
partying and the lights reject is 0.93
hopefully we can be that anyway and get
back past the eight point seven one but
I'm just saying it's not perhaps quite
as good as it could be let's put it that
way because we've use reserves within
that figure I suppose when we rolled out
from reserves it's usually the specific
purpose it's only sort measuring
performance against the agreed budget
even out hasn't moved on slightly from
the start it's in the airbag against the
budget that we've agreed for specific
purposes yeah I agree though there was
always a bit of movement in the air in
terms of thing it's just I'm trying to
paint the true picture absolutely where
we are and where we want to be so
dealing from that point of view it's
just about clarity losing okay thanks
I'm there any other questions please yes
come back okay
when you when you look at a one quarter
two and three budget it is